ja hallo ihr lieben grüße euch nochmal
hier ist nochmal der graf von unheilig
das sind zwei herzenswünsche bärchen
immer ein mädel und einmal ein junger
und die könnt ihr gewinnen
und gewinnen könnt ihr die in dem ihr
entscheidet ob die geschichte die ich
euch jetzt erzähle wahr ist oder falsch
ist also ich fange an zu vielen vielen
jahren bei meinem allerersten auftritt
habe ich mir aus versehen morgens im
halbschlaf euch gerade aus dem bett
gestiegen bin und zum konzert fahren
musste mein bart abrasiert ich habe das
selber nicht gemerkt sondern den leuten
als ich dann angekommen dieses
aufgefallen und kurz vor dem auftritt
habe ich mir mit einem schwarzen edding
diese dreiecke quasi nachgezeichnet
hinter der bühne haben sich alle schlapp
gelacht und das publikum hat nicht
gemerkt und jetzt müsst ihr entscheiden
ob die geschichte wahr oder ob sie
falsch ist wenn ihr die beiden haben
folgt ganz liebe grüße von mir feiert
euch graf und es gibt nicht nur zwei von
den bären zu gewinnen ich muss mal
gucken wahrscheinlich kriegen wir zehn
von jeder sorte also richtig gute
chancen etwas zu gewinnen und es geht um
herzenswünsche ev die super organisation
die sich um schwerkranke kinder kümmert
guckt mal unten in den info text an der
vermehrung